so again the argument from the left is
everything is justified because trump is
bad and republicans are bad
and so everything is justified and this
extends to the realm of rioting
it does and apparently the only way to
stop all of this is of course to concede
to the left
right it's a beautiful circular logic
here republicans caused us to do bad
things
the only way to stop us from doing bad
things is to elect us
to do bad things but that can only be
stopped if you elect us
and then we do bad things because
republicans do bad things so
the circle goes okay so overnight there
were multiple reports in philadelphia
that 30 police officers had been injured
in riots following a fatal police
shooting
police responded to a domestic call just
before 4 pm on monday video shows
officers with guns drawn in a
neighborhood
initial reports said that a man named
walter wallace was armed with a knife
and refused calls to drop the weapon
you can hear officers yelling put the
knife down multiple times
videos show the officer shooting this
person multiple times
wallace was pronounced dead at the scene
a statement released from the mayor
and police commissioner said the
shooting was under investigation it does
not indicate whether it was confirmed
that wallace was armed apparently he was
mayor jim kenney said i've watched the
video of this tragic incident it
presents difficult
questions that must be answered i
recognize the video of the incident
raises many questions says police
commissioner daniel outlaw
no it doesn't it raises zero questions
you can see the video
the person at issue is holding a knife
he refuses to put it down
he approaches the police officers when
he is about 10 feet away refusing to put
down the knife they shoot him
because you know what you don't have to
do when you are an officer with a gun
wait for the person to come six inches
from you and then stab you in the
fricking face
that's a thing you don't have to do as a
police officer in fact
you know what the advantage of a gun is
for those who need this this little
lecture
you know what an advantage of a gun is
you can shoot people from far away
you know what negates the advantage of a
gun when the person's right up next to
you you stupid asses
i don't under like so the people what
were they supposed to do throw their gun
at him
the guy was approaching them with a
knife we have now reached the point
where the shooting doesn't even have to
be remotely unjustifiable to justify
rioting in our streets because america
is so
obscenely racist apparently apparently a
police sergeant was run over by a truck
he got a lot of delightful people
engaging in this sort of violence
all i can hope is that rural
pennsylvania shows up in droves
in droves to elect donald trump to
prevent this sort of stuff
from being okayed by city authorities
according to the police department at
least 12 at philly police officers were
hospitalized with various injuries
one of them was a a 56 year old female
sergeant
she was a 56 year old female sergeant
okay where's the defend all women crowd
56 year old female sergeant hit by a
black
pickup truck in stable condition with a
broken leg other officers were injured
and bricks were thrown at them but you
know they're just bricks
no big deal they're just bricks who
cares just bricks
but you know what if you hate all this
if you hate wokeness if you hate the
the woke left and the radical left the
only way to stop all of this
well the only way to stop all of this is
to vote for joe biden
see how this works because the right has
driven the left so crazy
that now the only way to stop the left
from being crazy is to elect the left to
power
the only way to stop the wokeness is to
not elect donald trump is to elected joe
biden who is enthralled to the radical
left
if you enjoyed this video be sure to hit
the thumbs up button and share it with
all of your friends